[Music]
so hello guys welcome to the evening
right Tuesday Tuesday my bet is it
welcome to Tuesday is an insane end game
we exact name of this is Indiana game
yeah exactly so I'm good as the title
suggests we're gonna be talking about
end games and in this one hour or
something cause I will mostly be mostly
talking about the rock end games but not
only about that also about what is they
should be the thing in the end games and
what is the transition to transition
sometimes from and from different end
games to rock X let's say whatever like
say rooks and knights and bishops and
basically how you can trade off them and
to get to your favorable rock and game
for instance or with heavy Queens well
with heavy pieces like Queens and rooks
so I can trade let's say Queen and rogue
and then get to the endgame broken game
and they make sure is favorable so but
before that I want to serve a simple
study and in this simple study
it's white to play I think many people
know this study but anyway it's very
instructive so if you guys are following
I will give you maybe like a minute to
think about it and then I'm gonna show
the solution it's very instructive
opinion and shows how much precision is
required in rockin games and there's the
same basic that we all rock end games
are drawn well that's sort of not it
it's interesting faba is definitely not
true because some of them are winning
some many of them are drawn but like my
ultimate also winning so it's a very
first very soul and there's various fine
line between them so the source of this
puzzle is of course of course is on what
needs to push the pawn and right now
black has to give lots of checks in
order to try to stop this pawn and I'll
get to a C file so room d6 King
businessman by rock d7 so this is this
is wrong
now it's a draw therefore black and
white has goki be fire of d5 King before
Ruby for and go down the bore king be
free room d3 King c2 and the bow rock d4
is very key move and right now the
blacks idea is that if c8 Queen then
Roxy for and is a drops out of southern
rock quintic c4 in the stalemate so the
only way to win this is to play rook c8
rook and the idea is that rook e8 right
now is the mate in two threat therefore
the only way to stop is to play rock a4
and after okay folders can be free
hitting the rock and Roxy one mate so
and black loses because of those two
frantic cannot deal with so this is a
solution and I think it's very
instructive because it shows how much
precision is required in the end games
especially ruined games even like here
rock see it rock probably to the rock
not the queen is very important
sometimes we to under promote in order
to win so starting with that I wanted I
would like to proceed to the some of the
games that I played and I'll start with
the games that I lost in 2013 and it was
against a barrage of off and it was I'm
basically was killed just to the end
game simply because the the rest in
mother has much basically out of the
opening up type of black and the out of
the opening I got very good position
against timer and slowly I mean like I
made some mistakes unfortunately and
they we end up in this rock end game
were wife has definitely really good
chance I mean like relatively good
chance because spawn up but on the other
hand black has very solid position
should be should be just draw with
correctly and until at some point I was
playing well but then I managed to mess
it up and I was eventually game but the
thing is in such end games
it's not about basically how to win
because technically the correct defense
is just a draw but how to create the
biggest practical problems for the
opponent and this is what timer dudes I
think per perfectly and eggs are a very
great technique and put me in in in
difficult we put some difficulties to me
and in the end and in time pressure and
also there was team competition and the
gay this game was dependent on the
resolve the entire match I felt you know
huge pressure and I and I felt
eventually in a very simple endgame so
let's see what's let's see how time we
managed to put some pressure on me Roxy
one active in a rock correct h5
usually putting this postpones on f7 g
6h 5 is the best
defensive idea here for for black but
white still has some ideas here
so King h2o ultimately in the King roopd
- King Joffrey correct King e6 all good
I close but kept King on g7 doesn't
really matter look f1r okay - look if -
is it very important because right now
earlier I mean here in this position for
instance I put some pressure on g2 and
the King cannot freely go to a 4 because
the pawn will be lost on g2 therefore
white needs to and activate I mean
kicker the my rope from the second rank
and which was a little bit uncomfortable
and the next king before is a little bit
uncomfortable so Rock f1 or f2 is very
nice idea that table plate and after
this my rook has to go out of the second
rank so rugae Toruk f2
okay walking a for king of 6 rug dick -
now white cuts perfect setup working on
a4 or a5 roopd seven dozen tree
monitoring around chief free rogue a
free posting putting some pressure on
the 3rd rank so far so good
a both sides have played well like time
managed to activate his pieces but and
put some level of us the pawns on a king
side but still black didn't do anything
wrong and position still should be drawn
off correctly so against a maneuvering
around King g7 was a maneuver in
maneuvering and just staying in place
and finally break from whoever this move
there basically as last 10 moves as I
indicated there is no possible any
anything but cannot do anything
literally here in order to win so g4
happened and
for instance another idea of pushing the
pawns forward push FF
upon an e4 e pawn forward doesn't really
bring anything for instance Rudy forgave
3 if 500k 5 kinky for a 1f for just Rob
you are and just you know million checks
and hitting on G Freeport all the
exchanges of the pawns will just lead to
simplifications and just draw so there
is no way that this can lead anywhere so
therefore at MLG 4 which is correct
hdhdhd for a king - is difference
important here is I think the best
attempt for black for white to try to
win this to basically trade off agent G
pawns and keep this f3 e4 pawn vs f7
because if this is because this reduces
kind of like the control blacks control
over the squares on the fifth rank let's
say pawn on d6 controls a v square where
black white skin can go and right now
it's not I mean after h5 it will not be
possible anymore to base will cover this
square and white scheme may be can just
jump into you know f5 square maybe put
some check some work linking f6 or
something like some ideas so this is the
best attempt because packing on a G F G
upon doesn't lead anywhere is H upon
doesn't Rico anywhere is just a dead
drop there's nothing what can do but
Kinte g4 with idea h5 and threading this
pawn is a really nice I mean the best
technique and right now we can't forget
what the objective here for for both
sides
objective for both sides is basically to
activate the pieces the as much as
possible is same the same rules that
apply in middlegame same thing applies
an endgame but piece has to be active
and right now my king is well placed but
my Iraq seems to be well placed but
could be placed even better and the
thing is that I would have the the best
sort of defense here is to play Ruby 1
basically keep the rock active and there
are lots of tracks available from the
back ring Ruby g1 and maybe princess if
white goes okay father maybe rook a ruby
walking a fork edge ones possible
harassing the h4 pole which is not
and it'll clear how it can you know
continue and let's say if H five then
still there are lots of checks available
also keep keeping behind the pawns stop
them from moving forward
King g7 a second a five okay but like
still we keep on the key block active
behind the pawns f4 row gauge one for
instance available checks from h5 for
instance if five just Rock a one there
is no even no break for really possible
and Roxy severed let's say we can keep
also rope from on the fifth rank which
possibly could stop in e6 in any case
and there is no any possible
breakthrough in my opinion the only
possible breakthrough that could be
basically through a six but we don't
with the rook on the fifth rank is
basically impossible
so therefore the game is just drawn and
the only idea that I can think of here
for wise to play King g5 or something
like this Ruby five and seven let's say
trying to prepare a five but this is
done anywhere because after f5 there is
even up takes e5 so just draw rook takes
e5 just to show f6 is just dead wrong
king of seven f6 of course King f8 and
just drop therefore this was the best
defense I'm king of six is no it's okay
doesn't spoil anything but love would
move in the wrong direction here that's
why I don't really like it and I wasted
some tempest with this King as we will
see in the next couple of moves as I say
I was here on the big pressure and I
because it match was one half one and
half and I had to make a drawing this
version a my game think you know against
Rajah of Saturn game is not not an easy
task
how from psychological perspective
rather than chess perspective was tied
because of course is the draw but like
you still need to make this dress so
it's kind of tricky so h5 GT x h5 rook
takes h5 again Ruby one was the best
defense activate the rogue on the front
the attack from e1 f1 maybe g1 move
checks
the bet is the correct square for the
rope basically like on the first rank a
packing is 6 which is it is okay but
it's not so accurate and right now f4
happened and this would never have
happened if I kept my rook on a b-1 for
instance if I played rugby 1 f4 then I
can for instance give millions of checks
from behind here can get free rook f1
you know just kinky free rudy one
doesn't matter can give for against to
keep checking and right now I can still
keep checking out can basically stopping
you broke a 1 or something like this
it's it's very very you know very very
little for white at what can do is most
likely just a draw so this was the best
defense but I played his King g6 move
which is ok doesn't spoil anything
it's still draw f4 f 6 by it's a little
bit tricky and right now table played a5
king f7 Luke a 7 q g8 and as you can see
in this position white the rook is on
the seventh rank my king is cut on the
seventh rank because of that and there
is some idea of king h5 which he'd
played and coming to g6 and attacking
attacking this attacking basically the
f6 bone and suddenly there are some
practical difficulties and yes it's
still a draw obviously with the correct
play route so I took up taxi for King g6
through g4 check King f6 and route
before and the service was correct and
this is theoretically drunk end game and
this is what I want to talk about this
rook endgame is directly drawn but as
you guys can see even grandmasters can
lose it if they are put under some
pressure or being short on time they're
like you know various factors that can
affect this but what I'm going to talk
about is how to make draw here with with
black and what kind of traps white may
have up in a slave that can pull and
which is exactly the term that I fell
into in this game so
let's say if King received a beautiful
isn't wrong but rook e8 King h7 okay
before we get there before we go to this
end game I wanted to briefly just you
know play some stupid move here with
white a king g5s a King f8 rock c7 and
Ruby six I don't talk about this end
game because this is very similar and
this is also theoretical draw and this
is Philidor position and the idea is
that if pawn black and white pushes the
pawn and basically you can broadcast
from behind rugby one King g6 and which
you want check and the basically just
draw can get 5 qf 1 there is nothing I
can do to run away from tracks and
otherwise if not emphasis there is no
possible improvement here for white so
this is a liturgical position that I
want to kind of like by the way show
rook a8 yeah but in this position of
course rook e8 happened King h7 and this
is important because my king is this is
surgical draw simply because my king is
on the right in the right corner in the
short corner sort of cold if my King was
not on each server on d7 then it would
be this person will be losing simply
because my king is misplaced and while
in this position I have lots of
possibilities of giving checks from the
side to the whites king having King here
it will be only staying in the way of
the rook and from the King side will be
a much less space for the rook to
- you know sort of give checks because
then the Durga chicks just King g7 and
that's it basic it's just one check in
the poem
no marches forward but here it there are
more squares and this it this is 30
called draw okay rookie yet
good move please just be one king f7r
okay one correct f6 Roo k 7f Ronin check
through p7 and right now
very important okay not only move but
the most accurate that saves rook e8
basically just keeping the rook on the
8th ring and stopping White's King from
entering the eighth rank it was accurate
defense was the best also rook a one was
making a draw it was a little bit more
complicated but in the f7 king of 6 is
also a draw so we just make the
president but there is no improvement
possible for white let's say rook e8
then rook a7 is just hitting on f7 and
there is no not possible to play cube D
7 because of aid and actually black wins
so also the key moves done doesn't lead
anywhere let's say here that I can throw
in a track which you want thinking about
is forced to come back and if Kincade
then the same thing basically okay 8th
King D 7 and
yeah just draw because even rotate seven
on location is not possible cause kindy
six ok still possibly a draw I forget
which I'm not already sure because the
trigger was still probably a draw but if
I want to make a draw of black it's just
to please look at faith and just take on
f7 that's it so Luke a8 and so and yeah
and here raja baath played really strong
move from practical purpose of course it
doesn't mean still a draw but the thing
is I was here like I know like him I had
a minute maybe it was like sixth hour of
the game or something here like maybe
five minutes I don't remember exactly
was seven years ago or six and a half
years ago stuff like that and in this
position he played route is six very
quickly I remember this I remember he
played this move very very quickly and
having like one minute here on the clock
I sort of panicked because suddenly is
not clear what kind of make move I
should make like it's not clear sort of
there are many possibilities but like
you know I don't really want to go to k1
because then just you know king will go
to the back rank and f7 that's it and I
didn't really see a move what to make I
didn't want to play Europe let's say CA
da da because there would be too close
or b8 I was world also be too close and
I didn't consider king smooth by some
reason King h6 or king a jacket of
course lose because of a gate but the
thing is the in this position there are
only two moves in the literal draw
either rook b8 basically just keeping
their work on the eighth-ranked and
there's nothing white can do it look a
little bit scary to me over the board
but there but it just works simply but
for instance just to show King g7 just
Ruby seven the the in White King comes
here then basically just King g6 happens
there is nothing what can do actually
hold on
if here sorry not to root not check not
check this must be my mistake because
now king of it and white wins but here
key g6 happens that's the idea and f7
key in g7 that's the idea obviously I
got tangled here so f 70 kg 7 and this
is just draw and therefore here after
this what I pay rotation which is a
losing but but the simplest move here is
King h6 in my opinion the King h6 just
keeping roof on the a8 and there is no
improvement available for white let's
say King g7 okay let's say e 1 then just
we can throw in a check now because R is
not only six and we will see you in a
second white rook only sees make such a
huge difference in the previously in
Group A seven let's say Ruby one crew k7
King avoid King g6 just draw and here
can be seven just King g6 and similarly
with rook be a like in g7 and it's just
a draw is important to not to be work to
move the king with rügen I ate kimchi
six f7 Kim G seven stops the pawn rook
a7 next that's it
draw however here a pleasure case seven
and I didn't sort of realize what was
the idea behind the Ruby C's I thought
there is some trick but I couldn't
basically remember and the thing is I
knew is the droids and game is a draw
and I remember I even looked at this
briefly before sort of the tournament
back then but I at the time of stress
and the type of you know like such
pressure
we just make irrational mistakes somehow
and this sort of like you know
sometimes sometimes it happens so rugae
seven King f8 and right now the thing is
that after King g6 move
there's f7 but with clack and this is
the huge idea behind to look observe
Ruby six Jack Ruby six move that the
right now f7 comes with check and that
basically the problem here while that's
why Luke a7 is a losing move and this is
how the game concluded okay seven just
broke a eight I just played now rook e8
and there is no way to stop the f7 ball
they upon coming to f7 so Luke a takes
f7 and there is simply nothing white can
we black can do in order to save this
rook a 7 just rook e1 King head next
so I just threw in a check King e7 but
the rest is matter like just pawns
unstoppable create and just King goes
away f8 Queen and this game over so it
was very painful loss for me but like at
least I learned forever I hope that how
to play certain games and what what what
to pay attention to what sort of tricks
why may have and how was the best
defense for the defending side so this
was one hand game I want to talk about
another endgame for instance is a little
bit more complicated this game I won it
was against Zoltan our machine was
Bundesliga 2015 I believe and here I'm
going to style this custom from the
Saints disposition in this position
white it is white to play and certainly
what is clearly better here there is no
doubt about it what controls the D file
what has active pieces and also the King
is a little bit safer for instance it
would be great if something like rook h8
world right now because let's say
through cage right King gate right
a queen h6 king GA the room deities just
made but it doesn't work yet because
rook takes d5 happens first and
eliminates this rook therefore in such
position I had I had to basically I
could see how to immediately improve my
position how to kind of get some huge
advantage or something that's why what I
did here is basically I try to create
some weaknesses for my opponent and the
only way to do that I think is by move a
4 here which is what I did and basically
suddenly was pawns here I see a 76 our
object of my attack which they support
the rooks on c5 and the border Rubin c5
will diversify support the e5 pawn but
like if I undermine the pawn chain on a
7 b6 suddenly reverse if I may add some
lines in some eyes feel uncomfortable
and pull if I also will feel our cover
because you know we will not be defended
and it actually is hard to come up with
a move for black here because for
instance if white black plays Queen e6
sadly there are huge problems on the
kingroot d6 the say Queen f5 by bagger
in Group H I'd suddenly and the same
idea that's earlier intervention Queen
h6 roopd Aiden's just wins
so here rub d6 King is the Queen 7 for
instance Queen d2 again when you in the
front of rocket ride maybe at some point
maybe not yet because the ribbon will be
hanging about so there is rook d7 maybe
look at some point still remains some
sometimes a threat but the mostly the
way group d7 is the big idea or this
room does nourisher which one but like
with such control over the D file white
clearly has huge huge advantage and only
probably matter of time when blacks will
start dropping some material here
so it's not so easy therefore my
opponent tried to defend by trading one
pair of rocks Luke takes d5 rook takes
d5 but this gives me huge control over
the fifth rank and considered I played
already a four I'm will have next move a
five and the our undermine both pawns
a7b six
so Ruby seven a five I create second
weakness and Ruby six was a good defense
and right now I've had some options here
and I decided to go for the most
straightforward one and especially even
though it was moved number three seven
and I still had like I remember like
fifteen minutes or something like this I
saw that I think I can simply just grab
this pawn here on a seven because I
calculated the line in which I can take
this pawn if but the thing is is made me
not so easy but from practical aspect
that perspective is anyway you know like
or alright to take this point all the
possibility was a six but I didn't
really see a follow up after this
because blacks position I was pretty
solid so I you know when I had an option
of grabbing grabbing the pawn I just
decided to do it so route d7 and here we
got basically nearly by force to the
rook endgame rook a7ii for C five days
but I calculated and I found the
satisfactory basically I there is no way
the black can stop looped xa5 Queen d5
loop takes a five
Ruby Ruby five but my opponent found is
raced from defense with 25.5 and
suddenly is not so easy for me to follow
like right now
dumb in to push false pawns even though
I'm two pawns up I mean so one pond up I
have to connected almost connected
postponed because there will be NC fast
but they're not Kali today I didn't play
before yet but anyway they seem to be
very strong but I didn't see how exactly
I can proceed here also here's some
ideas of attacking me on the King side
because let's say rook if I broke a free
could be an idea you know I couldn't
agree
kind of like see how can i play this but
the good thing is that we reach our a
before this file like 20 of time even
though that I still had like 15 minutes
but like I told you have time to think
about this position and at the time at
the board I thought that I had kind of
just you know the simplest the cleanest
and the nicest way to win this game and
basically I decided to turn to go into
rook endgame and I didn't see any
defense for my opponent but as you guys
can I guess suspect there is a defense
for my opponent and in this broken game
that happen in the game and I want to
discuss briefly other alternatives
because the main focus of course the
okay I just wanted to talk about
alternatives there was move like before
obviously but I didn't see what happened
after Chris c4 and I didn't never wanted
to play class move like Queen d2 because
suddenly free and my King is under
tremendous pressure takes and g5 for
instance takes h4 like okay black
sacrificed free pawns
okay it's dumb free pawns but suddenly
my king is very weak and who knows what
hold on Scott Scott what's going on
there those of wadiya's perpetual and so
on it's unclear whether I would you know
whether is waning or not other
possibilities for instance to k1 Queen
before Lucas e1 but this also having
been minded there is limited material
Roxy fantastic enjoy Quincy free I
wasn't quite sure how white can win this
because there is only one weakness
sort of the only strength on white
positions with the C 5 C 7 pound but if
I can create second weakness though we
know when the whip wouldn't be possible
to win for instance such line like the
Quincy for King g7 Roxy 6:23 offering
the Queen trade also
when a free vital trade quiz with some
perpetual maybe every it's not so easy
to win this so another possibility here
was for instance rook a four but this
looked very awkward to me gift possible
to the rooty five robbed III it looked
very very weird and I didn't like it
therefore I just out of simplicity for
the sake of simplicity I mean just to
decide to play okay for this well I did
okay for Queen txt 5.65 Luke 65 rock
texif or and I thought this endgame is
simply winning simply because I my rook
is not on before but my rock is on III
and from I'm defending this big free
pawn from the side and then I bring my
King to the pawn and I simply start
marching at this point and there is
nothing what black could do that's what
I thought and I calculated some lines
here and in my opinion at the time it
was all correct and actually I fought
for a ball like this for quite quite a
bit that it was just very strong I
remember my teammates of also coming to
me after the game was really the day I
came up with but in reality black has
won only defense that is completely kind
of like computer like but there is logic
behind it and this logic I wanted to
discuss rook see free is okay
a rookie free Roxy to King f1 I'm trying
to drive the King to the King side
quitter I mean to the be free pawn
Ruby - and right now my entire idea when
I was playing this rook a fluke a
foreign transitioning to this rook and
game was to play f4 I saw this like from
far behind and I thought that this is
simply winning for white because as you
guys can see rook protect this pawn
protect this pawn this pond protect this
pawns
everything is protected my king is free
I thought to go here to see one kick the
rook out and then start pushing this
beep on and I didn't maybe put broken be
free as well and I didn't see any
counter play for my opponent even and I
calculated quite a bit here and one I
will show one of the lines I calculated
but the thing is I didn't see any
difference here from opponent so for
instance in the game happen king of six
I'll show how far out the game ended and
what and then what
black would help could have done
different in order to save this the game
so King f6 and serenely losing move King
G 1 and now my this is how my idea works
perfectly and that's why I'm really sort
of happy that you work because it's
really nice idea after all
too bad it tactically doesn't work in
one of the lines and this is the only
defense there's one defense it basically
which it doesn't work but here it works
so kinky one and the game followed like
Roxy to other removal attacking at five
which is logical but doesn't really
solve blacks problem because Kim D 1
let's say King g4 king c1 rook a to and
just before follows and just winning
putting broken be free pushing the pawn
king comes and that's it basically
there is my rook perfectly protects g3
pawn and the best case the all the
points will be exchanged by f6 g5 but
then it's still having behind the pole
and my king
running again supporting this pawn is
baby will be winning for white this was
the entire point and you've also look I
to just Kings one I can start and play
before something is just winning so but
so here I can play Roxy - it's sort of
like trying to put the room in front of
the pawn body if you have to put in
front of the pond when he was earlier
behind the pond it's definitely as sign
that something went wrong so rook c8
after just came to Ruby 8th King c3
there is pretty simple straightforward
just supporting the pawn with the king
and rook covering both Queen King side
pawns and also supporting this B pawn
the rook c8 attacking Beto
being on route 5 restricting the kink
further idea maybe King C freaking d4
I mean King c3 before and if King c3
rook c8 King before Ruby yet I can play
King C for Roxy and I Roxy 5 for
instance let's say some random move
let's Viki this this this this this this
and now rook c5 the idea of Ruatoki 5
they tell me and I can just push this
pawn forward before pawn push forward so
my plan play rugby a button up taking c3
rook c8 exactly what happened Roxy if
Ruby a root d5 my opponent player Roxy
won and are played before g1 rookie free
again covering this Geoffrey pawn and
already I made huge progress because
blacks King didn't do anything only
jumped around with the rock and making
already got to before and fully support
means before one Ruby one King see for
threatening Ruby free and here is my
opponent here is were my own I resigned
and the idea of a 4 and rook on if risks
covering entire third rank supporting
all the pawns and allowing my king
basically go towards the b-pawn and push
it forward as yeah it's very nice and
worked perfectly in general in many of
such lines and many of such end games
this idea will exist it's good to know
that such idea exists I knew about it is
why I used it but in this particular
case it doesn't quite work and there is
one only defense for black that I wanted
to discuss from this position after
rookie f4 that black can huh black can
save this and here basically in such
positions the best okay if you would
let's think about this way if what can
go with the King to c1 and kick out this
rook from B to basically it came over so
the only way there is not any time for
passive defense the only defense that
can be kind of like
employed here is active defense and the
only active defense is basically by
trying to trade pawns on the queenside
aching side so therefore the only move
here is f6 with idea g5 and just trying
to trade everything and try to do it as
quickly as possible and because the
reduced material the chances for escape
just for draw for the defending side are
much bigger rather than with pawns all
right with wooden are more plans because
just creates more ideas more deflections
call it whatever but there's basically
it's just harder with less material is
usually easier to defend
especially pawn wise if there's less
pawns the our chance is to defend
because there are always some chance to
escape let's say some endgame which
basically what the things I can
sacrifice the look for the pawn but then
the will be left out of the pond which
can promote to the Queen and for make a
draw so f6 is only defense but and I saw
this a kinky one g 5f j XG v f2 h g5 HT
x g5 of course i need to take because
otherwise it's a vago king king d1 h g2
x h4 Jetix edge fortunately maybe
something like let's say here let's say
here and suddenly there are some issues
with h4 pot here let's say rookie for
maybe here it's not so easy to win this
anymore also is possible to play after
GT x h4 immediately rogue Agito
Sammy privilege for is a weakness and
it's basically objective of an attack
let's say Luke do you want maybe here
again maybe this is not the past yeah I
like the previous blind notice that the
king of six just proving the king
pushing the king forward making a 5
looks decent kicking the rook out also
there's possibility of Raja - Raja for
coming also with King to the Queen side
I don't think what has enough here to
win this therefore after this f6 I need
to take simply in order to keep my rook
protecting the g3 pawn
but okay King g6pd walk into a g5
logical king c1 and right now question
basically there is a question what to do
of the rook because crook has to go
somewhere about the questions were and
what I calculated in the game was route
g2 and I thought this is the only move
and this was calculated and it but in
here white really wins and this is what
the calculate was what I was hoping for
and what wins after before which is
really nice line clean g 4b 5b was
pushing the point cover which III takes
takes b6 h 4b 7 H 3 and B aid with Queen
with track and if this was not a check
you have been a draw because they're
four wide would black would have played
H 2 but would this move would be
available but right now it's not
possible because the Queen is checking
the king and it's just
winning for for white there is nothing
that white there's nothing that black
can do here so let's say kingi to
basically sort of like technique of king
b7 looking III okay if kimchi fries also
Queen each one possible but if let's say
King H store something is possible to
just to come like you know like like you
know slowly move by move to the king and
basically eventually Queen Queen come to
g4 and king will not be able to move
anywhere and then king will just come to
the f2 and is just winging pretty simple
so this is what I calculated through g2
and this is what I saw actually if I
remember correctly when I played already
okay for when I was transitioning to
angry because mother was my entire idea
and the sort of idea of trading
everything with g5 and so on I cover at
first so I saw that but there is a
defense that there is a defense here for
black and this is extremely extremely
instructive opinion and I'm surprised
myself that such defense exists because
it's completely inhuman outside so here
lukkage to this only defense there is no
nothing else works nothing this is the
only thing that works here and this is
this is it this is a draw and the idea
here is that after
because in this line with g2 line before
I for doesn't really lead anywhere
because this just takes and black king
is forced to take and this king is very
badly placed on h4 and this is very far
away
it doesn't do anything and I can just
keep pushing for instance and she's just
winning over 3 g5 to be free that's it
if route g7 or something just I can keep
pushing through b7 will be free king to
the side g5 it should be winning king k3
maybe it's not British maybe maybe I
should be more careful here didn't quite
take this computer and so on but yeah
that's the second bit to make sense
makes perfect sense
Ruby 7 Ruby free and basically just King
comes and this should be winning and not
to be free but King freaking a4 or maybe
even King freaking C freaking c4 depends
this should be win because this King is
so far away that this can be a draw
basically but with rockin H 2 there is
huge difference relative to regarding
the regular
comparing to this time of rockin g2
because after before there is move like
h4 and after a GTX h4 rook takes h4 the
king is closer to the Queen side and we
rock h4 black immediately puts pressure
on before and I don't have really time
basically to bring my own King to the
pawn and I'm forced to basically defend
with my rock
Ruby free and and this basically allows
blacks King basically to just run
towards b8 square or like to King Queen
side in general and stop the pawn and
this basically just the draw let's say
b5 just King g7 b6 and rook b8
just stop in the pond b8 guru comes to
be f king of King King comes to c6 for
instance and just draw that's it
very instructive because it's very
active defense very active defense that
is what I was saying in such n games
there is no time for you know like you
know that you can make you know few
moves here and there and then hope to
make a draw
no you have to play active in such a
games you just have to play make active
I mean defend actively so root I search
for hitting on before and this is this
is it basically because it would be
freaking of six
I was thinking also maybe can be too but
then just King this very close and this
is just a drop King is right there and
it's third you can't draw and there is
nothing what can do therefore after
before is a draw and here I was also
thinking maybe some idea like King be
one and this is actually very tricky
move because here
h4 actually loses and this is the this
is why this is why this move is very
tricky because H for right now losses is
only White's hope because you take H for
Robert XH for doesn't hit on before
point and what it's in time to play Kim
b2 and just bring the King White's King
is cut on the efile well because of this
rope only if I'll and this just game
over is simply winning with Pompey pawn
can't be stopped but h4 is of course not
necessary and black has many many moves
I can play and you know it's just a draw
let's say even move like King f5 just
bring bring a little bit closer to the
Queen side and if only before happens
the H fork and just draw with the same
idea and move out before what cannot do
anything let's say fruit goes let's say
here already candy forest possible or
kinky far as possible king c1 back into
five back at least so it's just that
draw here so I found this defense with
rook H 2 H 4 rakat exit for extremely
instructive and very resourceful
because you just need to while defending
interesting to play actively in certain
games especially when opened stronger
superior side right now has defended
everything the only way to try to win
the defend this is to play actively by
trying to create active counter play and
this is the only way there is no nothing
as the computer worlds and what happens
after with passive defense King of six
this is what happens this is how I want
the game against Dalton and ammachi
which I was really happy to win about
I wouldn't do that if he found his f6
and then related to which is crazy so
this is an agreement to show and if I
hope it was instructive save it and
another one I wanted to briefly show is
another example of defense another
example of defense that I played long
time ago in bill in Switzerland it was
turn to open tournament and I played
against at he bon bus car on out he
bought from India grandmaster from India
and in this endgame in this game I mean
I played was black and my open opening
he went really really bad like I got
terrible position of the position of the
of the opening I couldn't remember my
analysis and so on and I ended up
basically trying to hold words and game
which is objectively lost with correctly
but I nevertheless I managed to do it
and let's see how I made that happen
so route d8 yeah basically a last two
moves be free threatening a four and I
didn't see a way how to defend this
Bishop because a free
I mean a5 a4 Bishop Isaac's will just so
awful this bishop on e6 so I didn't want
to do that because most free pawns are
so powerful that with by playing the say
a five here a for Bishop a six
I mean this can work this can never work
even these just these six just just
crushing just completely crushing so I
therefore I decide play actively room d8
he hidden d5 pawn and they for
[Music]
yes my bishop is lost but the question
is a position in general is lost there
is no doubt about this
the white is completely winning here
taking the bishop back and having active
rooks basically there is nothing black
can do from let's say computer
perspective because computers are just
complete you mean for for white anyways
but over the board is not so simple and
I think that I came up with the best
practical defense that I could come up
with and again I was solely relying here
on active activity of pieces activity of
my rocks activity a solver of my king
maybe not as much as king but like rooks
and trying to basically and but most
importantly controlling trying to at
least attempting to to control activity
of his rooks for instance the most kind
of like natural move here to play is
rook takes d5 certainly you just you
know you take the pawn it takes be 5/8 X
b5 yes we are still pond on but maybe
you have some chances we activate our
rook yes but it's but there is big
problem with this and we are realize it
during the game because here c6 simple
c6 be Texas root X is six and whites
rooks are much much more active than
mine there are possibilities of rock c7
next maybe it's a look-see 8 maybe Roxy
87 there are so many ideas with the
active row consists six that basically
is just completely lost there is no
defense for black
they're also ideas maybe seven rook a
one sometimes if the rook from d5 goes
somewhere possibly to possibly idea to
checkmate on the back rank so with
active rock on c6 there is basically
basically nothing that the black back
can do here and I realized it therefore
I played very very strange move but
nevertheless the only chance that I saw
during the game which was c6 giving the
give putting the pawn putting the bishop
under the pond and what can certainly
take it but which is funny what is even
strong here under the move the strong
here is d6 it's not as strong as the
Texas's but also possible which is how
good post position is that even d6 is
possible just you can ignore this bishop
and just keep postpones only 66 which is
you know sort of funny because however I
don't think it is easy to win this but
it's still possible I remember triumphs
Commodore was giving some big some big
advantage still but okay the Texas is of
course the correct the most correct move
and the best object with the best move
beat xe6 but here we got this position
and in contrast to the previous position
group of 365 and the 8xb 7580 XB v right
now balls two pawns try to restrict the
whites pawns it's sort of three versus
two but they're sort of restricted this
pawn on e6 is also sort of stopped by my
king only on eight hopefully getting
twister and but and also you can see
what through broken c3 is not gaining
anywhere to c7 because you can't my
opponent will try definitely and this
will have in the game but it's not
coming there yet and my rook on the
other hand on the D file and I will try
to basically activate rook d5 maybe Rudy
- maybe Ruby for I have some you know
squares for my rogue where I can put it
in order to activate it and there are
some chance is definitely for me - if
what messes up something is definitely
there are assumptions the civil Roxy for
a commander maybe maybe if a five
suddenly was this pawn chain is not
because
idea is route before obviously try to
activate here I can play a five and
suddenly the tropism getting there there
are some tricks here that I can you know
sort of use in order to try to save this
game and here my opening plate or key
figure is correct
attacking this g6 polish example forced
me to play a g6 rogue a triple walking
under weakness
very correct technique h5 and right now
sort of my opponent focus on this rook
hd3 row gauge free and just sort of
continue the same pattern of attacking
my paws and tech g4 and surprisingly I
am not sure anymore if this is a win
anymore after the g4 because it's
surprising I'm two pawns down and he
seems like muffin still has initiated
here and it seems like it should be
winning but it may be not anymore and
it's resupplies Inc but this is the way
it is and that's why this idea of Bishop
c6 was creating the biggest practical
problems because here the only okay why
this wing but after only one IDI my
opinion maybe there is more but like the
one the cleanest idea that you would
have to play and find which is certainly
not sort of like in intuitive East 7 is
winning and this idea behind e7 is not
just to push the pawn for they can
basically drop or something but the idea
the main idea here is that after the
system of law group d5 before the idea
white idea is to play rook if free and
then route is six and both pawns on the
six rank are basically following there
there is nothing I can do to stop this
from happening just route if free rookie
six just came over
I'm just dropping all the pawns and this
is it but same thing would have happened
if I just played in earlier rook takes
d5 and go for this position of Durkin
six
in general white needs to activate the
rook and I wait activate the rubies
through rookie free rookie six which is
not easy to find over the port because
usually it's seven you want to put
recent just to promote but you are not
promoting anywhere because my king zone
yet so what's the point of playing is
seven therefore you want to activate in
some other other pattern or the other
way let's say Fuji for installed my
opponent did so he creates the best
practical chess is my defense and here
my open play g4 which is a mistake and
suddenly after look the five is not
least not easy anymore gtx h5 and why
it's not easy because I'm hiding on c5
and if before suddenly all those pawns
are maybe a little bit weak a5 is
possible also rudi forest possible
suddenly their weaknesses and what's the
camp that i can i can actually attack so
she takes h5 my opponent play and right
now
it was move three six hours i remember
time trouble here and I couldn't I made
a mistake because I play Ruby g5 but
monopoly also didn't figure it out I was
supposed to play a medley rogue h5 t h5
t h5 which basically is nearly the same
thing will happen in the game only the
difference is Kim Ji Won which is I
think irrelevant because after rook g5
he could happen you know g3 and this is
very also hard to understand but the
idea is I thought when I'm playing with
fire that after we g3 I can I guess keep
both rooks on the board but the boom and
try to create some chances but the thing
is after before and white white rooks
are more active actually than mine and
with being two pawns up creating some
ideas like Rudy 3e 7 roopd 8 there is
nothing I can do let's say rook H 4 is 7
we've idea Ruby frutti 8 it basically
came over so I have to play rook F 4 and
then I just drop one pawn on d6 then
comes to CC basically is just waiting
for white so I look G free I didn't
really really want because just improved
to improved version of the entire thing
for y because pwnage v is a weakness and
this is just lost my opinion just King
g7 just a 5 which is also not easy move
but basically similar idea to previously
I should
in the game against Almaty that here
maybe rupee for comes protecting all the
pawns and the king bee just comes here
and that's basically sort of like to be
some sort of troops fun at some point
also before the six idea just trying to
enter again six rank Dec critical ideas
of course the sixth rank here for white
twin but ok map on I was lucky here hit
map and is spotted keep taking each one
and here we got this end game which is
basically I think drawn because there is
no way black and white can stop rook a
free or rook f5 and if heating of all
spawns you can stop one but you cannot
stop the other so let's say your King G
to have five King G free a5 for instance
the we don't have to take it on it see
if I doesn't run anyway first better to
stop blockade on the Queen side bring
the King and then take the poll and
suddenly is active on my rock and you
know pawn is this block i have active
rock I may be playing C 5 c4 next and it
just seems like I draw and this looks
like it to me so it's not so easy for
white to do anything here anymore and my
opponent played if I've trying to be
more active to send and prevent me from
playing root of 5 and project in c5 and
attacking on h5 so multi-purpose move
pretty good but on the other hand
it loves rook F 3 and I'm hot and I'm
attacking right now this be free pond
and there is nothing what can do to stop
this you know brood save the spawns
let's say if before for instance I can
play Europe f4 for instance I'm still
gonna get this pawn and after up to h5
roof days be free and here I will I
remember I wasn't sure where there is a
draw or not but I felt like a pretty
good chances because of activity of my
rook and the fact that his pawns are a
kind of like loose
none of them are connected all of them
are sort of loose I can attack them and
the most important thing his King is
still on each one
it's still on the first ring that's why
I'm think that if even evils on Geovany
wouldn't make any difference as long as
it's not let's say on e5 or d6 it should
be draw this one was kind my feeling and
actually proves correct because here my
point if he plays kingi SEC g2 I go
quick quickly king salmon rocky six
point looking five look before I'm
attacking like again active defense
there is no time for any passive most I
have to go active route before a5 just
okay for just kick and take the pawn and
again active okay one and push the a
pawn rook rook from behind
a5 a4 should be a draw should be a draw
h5 let's say five rookie for let's save
just giving to start giving checks it's
not not easy anymore to win this it
should be a draw of correct play that's
why I think rook h7 was the best try
basically trying to keep my king cut on
the seventh rank as well same like
asking his kick his fingers on the first
track my king will be on back rank as
well so this is the best I think defense
and let's say Ruby free okay seven root
x e6 Ruka Alex a six in attacking the
pawn but knocking d7 okay seven king c8
still my king is cut on the back rank
while they still the pawns up but what
spawns remain to be under kind of
disconnected there's like a pawn chain
that I can I cannot move or whatever I
can still play rookie v next and because
this King is still on each one is not
easy to win this I think probably it
should be a draw in my opinion because
let's say rook g7 or kevsharon doesn't
really matter would be five Kim G to
rook takes e5 h for route d5 a nice text
are pushing my pond is if the king was
already on g4 or something then maybe h5
would be possible but right now with
rocket on d5 is still let's say
protecting from from the pawn h4 pawn
marching forward and if rook g5 I think
there could be some idea like Ruby for
maybe hitting both bones which is
already not so easy to win it's
know that in here it was impossible
because h5 k 4h six Andrew Paige 4-h
seven wins because Ruby g8 + HH Queen
but in here with if the rook is already
on g5 is not possible anymore simply
because after h5 takes h6 rook H for H
sin is not possible because Ruby's not
rook the rook is not on g7 so this is
drop therefore so yeah I was thinking
that here R which is 7 this roopd 5
maybe c5 of course I didn't see over the
borders it would make after a game aa
analysis but like C 5 C 4 and basically
white black it definitely has some
chances to save it
especially it's all limited material as
I said in the previous example with the
limited material the chances for
survival like increase sort of
exponentially like really is there like
if black defensive side can trade pieces
I mean to trade pawns simplify the
position there are lots of positions
that are basically hard to win because
just because there is a little material
left on the board so this is good idea
to remember when while defending let's
say here King a phrase just c5 yeah and
then c4 c3 hopeful hoping for to push
the pawn forward if the rook plays some
roof or something I can activate my King
as well possibly what history has some
chances not saying that not only while
of course pushing his for a win but with
correct i black i think should save it
throws the best attempt here but after
okay Jade suddenly my open and what my
opponent played it's not when it's not
the win anymore I think he want to be
more forceful let's see okay Jay King g7
rook c8 trying to hit on c6 but it's not
working anymore right now okay free a
rook takes and this is just draw rook
rook c7 it was nice trick
rook CC would have that basically
similar position as in the game but
Rustin was nice three because right now
I can't stake because rook takes is 16
d5 rook a6 King c5 and came to NZ
with two points here this is winning I
can't
I mean we're black here same time save
myself from you know controlling both
marching both both both pong ball of the
pawns it's just impossible there is
there's too many threats too many ideas
White has to block has to control you
know to save it is impossible to make a
draw here
therefore I play King as he was very
accurate and this actually the end of
the game because the rest is very pretty
simple rook takes c6 rook a for Luke in
g2 Roxy for I'm basically attacking both
spawns again and I'm by again going for
active counter play a5 a4 and a3 and
deflecting the rook then taking c5 e 6
pawns and will be left out of the h-bond
only and this is just that draw and so
this is how the game ended and I managed
to save this game after really big fight
and struggling to make it row but alas
made it so King G free a fire let's see
how the game ended HH for a for h5 Roxy
freaking G for Roxy for is always to
find some tracks like that in Geoffrey
Roxy free king a fortress ok now a three
h68 too funny Luke a6 is forced again
check just to kick the King out do a
third rank kingi free okay I undertook
just to make sure that King even goes
further can your free but okay I just
decided found it to just take it upon do
you want to make it complicated just
took the pond another one and there is
nothing that what can do it's just to
the material pond which this is all an
only point and my king only six is very
close to this pond so this is basically
it here okay seven
rock h2 would have been met by okay rook
c8 and then King comes to very quickly
there is no I can just picking f7 more
accurate and if here I can even go
kimchi a for instance also can give joy
Roxy fire which is a draw anything makes
the draw here so my open player okay
seven I play king of 6h 7 and our gauge
5 and right now okay only important
thing not to play king g6 because we're
a six whiz
but just rook h1 keep the behind upon
now king g6 and it's just this is just
wrong
so this is how the game ended I some
people may say I was lucky I would agree
with that to some extent but also I
think I demonstrated the best practical
resources that I could have found in the
position and I put the most practical
problems as I could only to my opponent
and it worked out but most important
sort of like take us from this game is
active defense and controlling activity
of your open as well so yeah that's all
I have I think for today for the routes
and games and I hope it was instructive
and I will see you guys next time thank
you bye
you
[Music]